mehr als 140.000 tonnen lebensmittel
kommen täglich per luftfracht allein
nach deutschland einem typischen
industrieland in dem es fast alles zu
kaufen gibt oft haben die waren eine
halbe weltreise hinter sich wenn sie in
den regalen der supermärkte landen
typische luft frachtgüter frische und
leicht verderbliche lebensmittel
der rest kommt auf dem seeweg an erster
stelle steht fisch aus afrika und island
gefolgt von gemüse wie spargel aus peru
oder bohnen aus kenia schließlich die
exotische obstsorten die papaya sklaven
und mangos aus afrika südasien und der
karibik doch wie klimaschädlich sind
fliegende lebensmittel im durchschnitt
verursachen nahrungsmittel aus übersee
rund elfmal so viel kohlendioxid wie
regionale produkte dabei schädigt der
transport mit dem flugzeug das klima am
stärksten
ein beispiel ein kilogramm spargel der
mit dem flugzeug aus chile kommt
belastet die atmosphäre 50 mal stärker
als die gleiche menge per lastwagen aus
spanien kommen die stangen aus der
region mit einem transportweg von
maximal 100 kilometern verursachen sie
gerade mal 17 prozent der emissionen des
lkw transport aus spanien
wer per rad zum feld fährt und dort
selber erntet ist unschlagbar
klimafreundlich er kommt auf null gramm
kohlendioxid und wie sieht es mit den
jahreszeiten aus die heimischen äpfel
die man im frühjahr kaufte haben schon
den ganzen winter im kühlhaus gelagert
bei 1 bis 3 grad auch das kostet energie
für die klimabilanz bedeutet dass äpfel
aus neuseeland können durchaus weniger
klimaschädlich sein als heimische äpfel
aus dem kühlhaus erst recht wenn sie
statt mit dem flugzeug per schiff nach
europa gereist sind
denn als schiffsfracht entstehen bis zu
200 mal weniger klimaschädliche abgase
als mit dem flugzeug
am besten aber zu regionalen produkten
greifen und zu dem was die jahreszeit an
gemüse und obst beschert